[Music]
thank you
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know this is a
question and answer program that airs
once a week and uh basically we take
your questions that you send us
electronically and we do the research
and then insofar as there is an answer
we try to find the answer by a study of
the word and then in our program we read
the questions and we try to answer the
questions that you send us let me give
you the email address that you can send
the questions to it'll be on the screen
TV at some tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org we'd be delighted to receive your
questions we have a large pile of
questions already unanswered uh it
probably will take a while to get to
yours but keep on tuning in and
eventually we will get to your questions
and try to provide an answer I have with
me
um my friend Daniel Miranda who is
associate speaker with Secrets unsealed
uh and mainly in charge of the Hispanic
work here at Secrets unsealed although
he does a lot of programs in English as
well and so we're glad that you're here
uh Daniel it's good to be here in this
program with you pasobar it is a
privilege to study the Bible together
praise the Lord praise the Lord and of
course we never want to begin any uh
religious program without asking for the
Lord's guidance so if I could ask you
the priests have a word of prayer as we
begin the program sure let's pray
Heavenly Father we come before you
awesome presence and we thank you for
this program
we recognize our inability to explain
the word of God and we ask that as we
open it you may enlight our minds and
you may help us
answer the questions
in the right way in the name of Jesus
amen amen
okay we have several very interesting
questions very captivating questions
today and I'm going to read the first
one and then maybe I can ask Pastor
Miranda to answer in so far as possible
uh this one is from Michael Bruce
Boucher I'm not sure I'm pronouncing it
correctly but
um the question is this
since the destruction of Babylon middle
Persia Greece and Rome was a fulfillment
of divine prophecy and then he puts in
parentheses prophets and Kings page 501
paragraph three was the kingdom that is
of Daniel 2 44 that was prophesied to
destroy these Kingdoms in existence at
the time of their destruction
so basically uh the in the in the story
that we find in Daniel chapter 2 all of
the kingdoms are destroyed at the same
time so our Babylon medal Persia in
Greece uh in Rome in existence when
Jesus comes when we know that
historically they passed from the scene
right so I think that's the question
that's being yeah I think that's the
question that our brother has
so basically when we find in Daniel 2
that the stone smites the image and
destroys all the kingdoms
it might imply or it seems to imply that
all these kingdoms were in existence
when Jesus comes once we understand the
stone is representing Jesus and his
kingdom but actually that's not the case
because the same chapter Daniel 2 we are
told that there is one Kingdom that
follows another in the interpretation
right that Daniel gives to the dream
that King Nebuchadnezzar had so if one
Kingdom follows another then it is not
possible for all the kingdoms to be in
existence when Jesus comes so let me
just go ahead and read the
interpretation that Daniel gives to this
King to this dream I mean and
so here in verse
that would be 44 maybe yeah but uh
a little bit before that in regards to
okay verse 38 this is the head of gold
and at the end of verse 38 Daniel says
you are you are this head of gold but
after you shall arise another kingdom
inferior two years then another
a third Kingdom of bronze which shall
rule over all the earth and the fourth
Kingdom shall be as as strong as iron so
notice that there is a sequence after
you shall arise another kingdom then
another kingdom and in light of Daniel 7
and Daniel 8 we know that these kingdoms
for example Babylon was overthrown by
middle Persia which was in turn
overturned by Greece which was in turn
overthrown by Rome
now why do we then find the whole image
standing at the time of Jesus is coming
well because even though these kingdoms
fell their characteristics prevailed
over time right and each preceding
Kingdom
inherited the characteristics of the
previous Kingdom and then we have all of
these characteristics
fused into the kingdom of Rome both
Pagan and pepperon and also the spirit
of Prophecy tells us that God not only
judges individuals in the investigative
judgment but he judges Nations as right
and so in the investigative judgment all
these nations will come into view
beginning in 1844. individuals as well
as Nations and what you mentioned before
we find an inkling of this in Revelation
Chapter 13 Verse 2 where it speaks about
a beast which was like a leopard his
feet were like the feet of a bear and
his mouth like the mouth of a lion and
the dragon gave him his power so you
have the same four beasts that are found
in in Daniel chapter seven you find them
here right and uh but this is one Beast
is a composite Beast because it is
composed of the traditions and beliefs
of previous kingdoms yes and by the way
that's the reason why in The Book of
Revelation the last power last human
power that opposes God is called Babylon
right which is the first Power in Daniel
chapter Two uh so so it would seem that
they're all simultaneous because they're
all destroyed at the same time but they
also lost their power before that when
the kingdom that came after uh ruled in
their place that's right
okay I hope that that is helpful uh in
answering the question that brother
Michael has asked uh here we find
another very interesting question
um this is from Ling Vang
I've got a question that has me stumped
for quite some time
this is regarding Joshua chapter 6 of
which the Israelites were told to March
around the city of Jericho question why
is it that the Israelites did not rest
on the Sabbath when they marched around
Jericho at least seven consecutive days
not only that on the seventh day they
marched around seven times more yes how
were they still keeping the Sabbath day
holy when there's no account of Sabbath
rest if they marched around seven days
it must have been one day it must have
been the Sabbath exactly so how do we
explain that
well I think the bottom line of the
question is what is Sabbath rest
because if I understand some of the rest
are still this uh not doing anything
then we would be troubled by this and
say that they broke the Sabbath because
they were marching on the Sabbath so the
question is
is marching on the Sabbath in itself
breaking of the Salas
or even more so
were they breaking the Sabbath when they
were doing what God had commanded them
to do there's the point that is the
point because uh well marching in itself
was not the problem and they were
actually marching not because they were
wanting to March they were not marching
because they were doing their own work
they were marching because they were
doing God's work and According To Jesus
and the Bible
it is good to do good
on the Sabbath day and doing good is
doing God's Will and this was God's will
for that specific day and I think
probably God knows best what is breaking
the Sabbath and what isn't yeah God
would not command them to do something
that involved breaking the Sabbath which
he had given right yeah in Joshua 6
let's give the scripture backing for
this in Joshua chapter 6 and verse 2 and
following it says and the Lord said to
Joshua see I have given Jericho into
your hand it's king and the Mighty Men
of Valor
and here comes the command now you shall
March around the city
and all you your you Men of War you
shall go all around the city once this
you shall do six days
and the Seven priests shall bear the
seven trumpets of rams horns before the
ark but the seventh day you shall March
around the city seven times and the
priests shall Brill the trumpets and
then of course when the trumpets sound
the city Falls so who is it that's
commanding to March around the city six
days and then March seven times around
the seventh thing it's gone it's gone
yeah so obviously God would not command
them to do something that breaks the
Sabbath exactly
and actually instead of
breaking the Sabbath
this shows us a deeper meaning of the
Sabbath because of what happened the
seventh day
here we find in verse 16 and the seventh
time it happened when the priest blew
the trumpets that Joshua said to the
people shout for the Lord has given you
the city now notice that the shouting
sometimes we think that they just
shouted so loudly that the sound was so
strong that just fell or brought down
all the walls of Jericho but actually
the shout was before the walls fell
because it was a shout of Victory it was
a shout of freedom in other words
of Victory 70s a day of freedom and
that's what we find here and there's
there's no coincidence that when Jesus
began his ministry in Nazareth uh we
find some very interesting words to this
effect about Deliverance Deliverance the
Sabbath and Jesus is saying this on the
Sabbath uh maybe we can just read I
think it's uh Luke chapter 4. and I
think it's verse 18.
um Jesus goes into the synagogue on the
Sabbath day according to verse 16 and
then he's handed the book of Isaiah he
chooses the scripture reading for the
worship service right and it says in
verse 18 that the spirit of the Lord is
upon me because he has anointed me to
preach the gospel of the to the poor he
has sent me to heal a brokenhearted to
Proclaim Liberty to the captives and
recover of sight to the Blind and to set
at Liberty those who are oppressed to
proclaim the acceptable year of the Lord
and I think another key is in Exodus
chapter 20 the fourth Commandment uh it
says remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy six days you shall labor and do all
your work now marching around the city
of Jericho was not doing their work no
he was doing the Lord's work amen of uh
Conquering the first city in Jericho
which would lead to the conquest of
other cities as well yes so they weren't
doing their work they were doing the
Lord's work and if God said March they
weren't breaking this happen this was a
holy war yeah the holy war there very
good point
okay I hope that this is helpful as
we've attempted to answer this
particular question uh here's another
one and the reference obviously is wrong
but it doesn't make any difference says
Dear pastors thank you for this
informative and rather edifying program
I'm loving it my question is this what
does Paul mean in first Timothy chapter
20 it says here but it's not chapter 20.
it's uh at the end 120 I believe yeah at
the end of the chapter
um when he says that he has delivered
himinius and Alexander under unto Satan
is he saying that he left them to their
own vices
uh so what does he mean when he has
delivered uh these two individuals to
Satan
that is a very troubling passage to some
people well before we go into the
context of First Timothy chapter 1 verse
20 we find a similar expression
in First Corinthians 5 verses 4 and 5
which actually have the same or similar
context I would say it's not the same
but it's very similar
uh the context of First Corinthians 5 is
uh incest in the church
and there is a young man that is
sleeping with his father's wife
and it seems that the church hadn't
taken measures with this case and Paul
writes in verse 4 he encourages that in
the name of our Lord Jesus Christ
when you are gathered together along
with my spirit with the power of our
Lord Jesus Christ delivers such a one to
Satan for the destruction of the flesh
that his Spirit may be saved in the day
of the Lord Jesus and my major in
reference takes me also to First Timothy
chapter 1 verse 20. so what is Paul
saying here deliver and to Satan when
here in the context is to be this
fellowship and be left to his own works
but then this is not condemnation
because it says for the destruction of
the flesh that his Spirit may be saved
in the day of the Lord Jesus Christ in
other words it is easier for God
to save someone when the person realizes
his own condition that when the person
is deceived and is under the church's
privileges while still in open sin
thinking that what he is doing is not as
serious before God now in the case of
jimeneos and Alexander that were
supposedly Christians
um Paul says I have delivered them to
Satan that they may learn not to
blaspheme I mean these were some of
Paul's enemies and Alexander the copper
Smith actually was the one that accused
Paul the second time before Nero and
that caused him great trouble and he
says in the second letter to to Timothy
this expression here may seem to me and
I don't know if you would agree with me
that
um
God Paul is just leaving this case in
the hands of God and God will do justice
to to what they're doing because they
profess to be Christians and yet they
are persecuting him that's what I
understand so basically all of God's
discipline is remedial
unless the person has gone beyond the
point of no return Yes and there's two
possibilities here that it's speaking
about uh in this particular text it's
speaking about these individuals
delivering them to Satan so that when
they're beyond the sphere of the church
they can think about how serious their
sin was so that then they can be
reincorporated into the church later on
I think that's that's the perspective
you're presenting right the other the
other possibility is that they've gone
beyond the point of no return in first
Timothy chapter 1 verse 20. not First
Corinthians chapter five because there
it says that their Spirit might be saved
in the day of the Lord so there was uh
there was a remedy in in First
Corinthians but there's a possibility
here that they've gone beyond the point
of no return they had opposed the work
of of the Apostle Paul and no matter how
much uh the Holy Spirit worked with them
they still were not going to accept so
the two possibilities are
you know
are possible sorry about the redundancy
but probably the one that you gave I
think would be more in harmony with
First Corinthians chapter five yeah even
though in the in in Alexander's case for
example second Timothy chapter 4 verse
14.
it says Alexander de coppersmith did me
much harm made the Lord repay him
according to his works
if it's the same Alexander if it is then
that seems like uh there was no remedial
situation in his case exactly so it
could be one of those possibilities you
know when a person is disfellowship from
the church they need to understand that
that's a very very serious thing you
know to be Beyond The Realm and the
protection of being within uh the church
there's something special about being
something protective about being within
the church and the fellowship of
Believers and the reason a person is
disfellowshipped is not to discourage
them amen or to you know to be
retributive in the discipline that is
applied but for them to to see man what
I did was really serious I need to I
need to come to the Lord and I need to
remedy uh the the sin that I was been
have been committing
so
okay well hopefully that is an answer to
the question
um let's go there's another one here
from the same individual that we
answered before Michael Boucher I'm not
sure if it's Boucher or boots
um but anyway uh he asks the same type
of question
but there's one that perhaps has a
little bit different Nuance the second
one was the literal shattering and
breaking of the kingdom of Babylon
accomplished by the kingdom of Grace or
by the kingdom of Glory well I don't
think that the shattering of Babylon
took place at either one of those
exactly it took place when when the
medes and Persians came and that fateful
night with the handwriting on the wall
and the kingdom of Babylon fell to the
power of the Persians yes exactly so
when we started the Bible we need to go
from what is more obvious and simple and
easy and then to the more complex issues
so when it comes to the kingdoms again
we mentioned it in the beginning of this
program
the interpretation that Daniel gives is
very clear
that beta Persia would destroy Babylon
so we kind of get around it and so
Babylon Little Babylon was destroyed and
shuddered by middle Persia
we already explained that middle Persia
would not be in existence when Jesus
comes but its principles will be right
okay so what's our next question
so our next question is about
amalgamation that comes from David
Molina this is a very interesting
question as well
it says in the book spiritual gifts
chapter 6 and I actually have here the
quote
this is specifically spiritual gifts
volume 3 page 75. that's what he's
referring to there is a statement that
talks about the amalgamation of man and
Beast Before the Flood and after the
flood
and she states that the amalgamation can
be seen in certain races of men
I find that something perturbing
could you please clarify what she meant
by those statements thank you David
Molina now
um
I don't think that will answer this
question at this point because we
already did almost an entire program on
this particular question and it's
available in the archives let's just
want to mention that you know we have
many many different programs with
different questions where you can go to
our icon archives and see the answers
that have been provided before we can't
just reinvent the wheel and every time
we have the same question to answer it
all over again when it's already been
documented also besides the fact that we
dealt extensively with this reading
different statements from the spirit of
prophecy on the issue of amalgamation I
wrote an entire newsletter article
analyzing all of those statements there
and that is available not only in hard
copy form but it's also available if you
go to our website
secretsunsealed.org you can go to
resources and then go to newsletters
after that and then you'll find all of
the the newsletter articles that I've
written and I wrote an entire newsletter
article on the amalgamation of man and
Beast so I would hope that the person
who asked this question will take the
time to go to our archives and they're
all listed there and you'll be able to
find the full answer to this particular
question
okay here comes another interesting
I have heard on a numerous numerous
occasions that Christ could have
abandoned his mission on Earth and go
back to heaven
notwithstanding that Christ had the
power of choice however
I'm having difficulty with that so I
would like some clarity on it
based on my understanding although I am
subject to correction
the father and the son made a covenant
that if man should sin the son would
come to redeem Humanity
taking into account that God cannot lie
and throughout the Old Testament unto
Christ's time numerous prophecies have
been given in scripture and Christ also
said that not one jot or one Tittle
shall in no wise pass until all be
fulfilled
he said I also said think not that I
cannot pray to my father and he shall
give me 12 Legions of angels Matthew 26
53 there's also the aspect that God
cannot be tempted with evil he's
faithful and many other holy
characteristics how could he have called
the Angels there and not sin because at
the same time prophecy would have failed
he could have also escaped from them
without the Angels when the people were
struck down like dead men but he didn't
so
this has to do with the foreknowledge of
God and the free choice of Christ how do
we answer this question
well the the point here about Jesus's
choice of going back to heaven and not
complete the work of redemption and and
the example that he gives about he
calling angels to defend him
the way the reason why this is expressed
like that
is referring to Jesus's choice that he
could have had that choice but he
decided not to do it but Jesus was
faithful to the Covenant he was faithful
to the word of the father he obeyed his
father here on Earth even though as a
human he struggled to follow his own
will and get seven if we hear him
praying father if we if it be your will
let this let this cup pass from me so we
see that that doesn't mean that he was
going to abandon his mission but he
struggled in his Humanity like we
struggle in our Humanity so that he
could give us example of how to overcome
so he struggled with doubt with
weariness and things like that so I
don't see any trouble finding these
aspects these things of Jesus and
um and of course
yes if he had abandoned his mission we
would have perished and that's very true
and he would have enough reasons even to
do so because we have broken the
Covenant but it was because of Mercy
that he stayed and saved us
the father knew
from eternity past
what the choice of Jesus would be
but the father did not choose
for Jesus the fact that the father knew
doesn't mean
that that God made the choice it simply
means that God knew what the choice of
Jesus would be
and and so uh and another important
point is that when Jesus was on this
Earth
he did not have access to the total plan
so it was a real trial you know when he
was in heaven the spirit of Prophecy
tells us that they both went over the
plan Jesus saw the entire plan from
beginning to end his whole Ministry he
saw before him but while he was on Earth
he only knew from day to day what the
father's plan for him was for that day
which means that when Jesus went through
his struggles it was a real struggle yes
the father knew what the result of the
struggle would be but it doesn't mean
that Jesus did not have a serious
struggle uh you know when he was when
Jesus said don't you know that I could
call 12 Legions of angels if I wanted
and my father would deliver me well the
father knew that that Jesus was going to
say that but it was Jesus who actually
said it yes and Jesus who made the
choice amen okay okay well
um you know maybe we can answer this one
uh in our next program because time is
really flying by I want to remind you
folks that you can send your questions
to us and we will research and see if we
can find an answer of course there are
mysteries in the Bible that have no
answer and I'm not sure that even in
eternity we're going to have the answers
to all of our questions we're going to
study forever and ever so we will always
have things to learn but we try to
answer as many questions as we can in
harmony with what we find in the Bible
and in the spirit of Prophecy once again
let me give you the address where you
can send us your questions TV at some
tv.org once again TV at some tv.org and
we will be glad to attempt to answer
your questions once again we want to
thank you for tuning in we ask that you
will please tune in every week and if
you've sent us a question eventually we
will get to that question blessing
things to you and we hope to see you the
next time
[Music]